AWS or Amazon Web Services is something
of a king when it comes to cloud
computing services no have you ever
stopped and wondered why it takes that
position I'm Rahul from simply learn and
these are the top 10 reasons to choose
AWS for your work requirements we'll be
going through each of these reasons one
by one in detail at number 10 we have
ease of use now one of the main reasons
for AWS to become this famous is because
how easy it is to use anyone can set up
an account or native list and start
deploying their services without having
any advanced programming language skills
now it's so easy to use that even a baby
can use it don't take our word for the
AWS puts their customers understanding
of their services first and foremost a
bless maintains a document for each
service under developer resources
listing how to use the aid of this
dashboard to deploy and maintain any
service here you can see the Amazon ec2
developer resources which contains a
vast array of information that the users
can use now say you wanted to access
easy to auto scaling you'll go to the
ec2 page you'll click on developer
resources find the Amazon easy to order
scaling and get the required information
that you need
number nine third party API so AWS API
means that you can manage your
cloud-based infrastructure through
various third-party software for these
third-party software include cloud
Ranger Quinta Li and tango card these
help you utilize all the time and cost
saving features that AWS has to offer
for example cloud Ranger helps companies
understand the cloud with visual
representation tango card that are
events rewards programs for businesses
and their customers worldwide
and quickly which provides social media
analytics for brands on a single
dashboard number eight dueling
scheduling is that you can start or stop
an AW service at period nine times that
is you can schedule a service to run at
a particular time or on a particular day
or even when a certain event takes place
now you'll be able to sleep a whole lot
better knowing that the services that
you want will be able to function on
their own without any supervision of
yours that is as long as you should
you'll them to work in a particular
manner
now if you've noticed AWS is all about
customers experience so AWS offers a
multitude of customization options to
ensure that the users experiences are
made easier and according to their
requirements customization options such
as customer define tagging allows users
to easily monitor and manage their
specific resources it can be used to
implement cross tracking security and
automation
number six a full stack of services a
double is provides a wide range of
services covering all your cloud
computing requirements now a tubeless
didn't become the cloud computing giant
that it is now without having such an
expansive array of services
it covers domains such as compute
storage database migration and so on now
if you do find a domain that AWS doesn't
cover at the moment it's probably
because a SS is working on creating
services on it as we speak here we can
see the array of services that AWS
provides these account to at least 100
services at the moment number 5 data
privacy in today's world there's nothing
more important than privacy and that's
something that AWS understands very well
data privacy is offered to each and
every a SS customer regardless of their
business size a double essentials data
privacy through physical security find
drain access and data locality control
there's also no additional cost for I am
I am or identity and access management
helps users control who is authenticated
and authorized to use the resources
number for availability
aw services are also well known for
their well built reasons the AWS cloud
spans over 54 availability zones and 18
geographic regions and 1 local region
around the world
these multiple availability zones ensure
that your data can be stored in a
multitude of locations that are of your
choosing now as you can look at the map
here each a w's region has multiple
availability zones and data centers
number 3 reliability and recovery
reliability is also very important
selling point of beta PS which is
achieved through multiple backups of
service at multiple physical locations
now without backup
in case of some disaster when data is
lost it cannot be retrieved as there is
no backup available now in the case of a
SS there's multiple backups available
that the data that one of the services
lost can be Lea obtained making it very
reliable to use flexibility and
scalability now aw services are well
known for their flexibility and how they
can order scale themselves as per our
requirements businesses don't have to
deal with the constraints of physical
computing infrastructure and can have
access to servers and storage on-demand
which means scalability or auto scaling
allows automatic increase or decrease of
resources as per the needs and the
flexibility in services means that you
can start or stop the service at any
time number 1 pricing now AWS has a
pay-as-you-go approach for pricing it's
about 100 cloud services now with AWS
you only pay for the individual services
that you need and for as long as you use
the
without having to pay for a long-term
contract or complex licensing now if you
can see the images below in an
on-premises approach once we bought a
physical infrastructure the cost will
always increase even as the demand
decreases the area in the pink shaded
region is what we have to pay even
further sources are underutilized in the
case of ADA players the only cost is
based on how much we use so at some
point you use more you end up paying
more it also has a pay less by using
more approach to promote higher usage as
you can see in the images below the most
storage required for s3 the lesser you
pay per unit per month I hope this video
helped you guys understand how helpful a
double use can be to satisfy your work
requirements thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from simply learn hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here